dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here have a
look at this magnificent idea the input
is a digital 3d model of an object and
the viewpoint of our choice and the
output is an easy to follow step by step
breakdown on how to draw it automated
drawing tutorials I wish tools like this
were available back when I was a child
awesome
this technique offers a way to create
the scaffoldings to help achieving the
correct perspective and positioning for
the individual elements of the 3d model
something that novice artists often
struggle with this problem is
particularly challenging because we have
a bunch of competing solutions and we
have to decide which one should be
presented to the user to achieve this we
have to include a sound mathematical
description of how easy a drawing
process is the algorithm also makes
adjustments to the individual parts of
the model to make them easier to draw
without introducing severe distortions
to the shapes the proposed technique
uses graph theory to find a suitable
ordering of the drawing steps beyond the
scientific parts there are a lot of
usability issues to be taken into
consideration for instance the algorithm
should notify the user when a given
guide is not to be used anymore and can
be safely erased novice apprentice and
adapt users are also to be handled
differently to show the validity of this
solution the author's made a user study
where they tested this new tutorial type
against the most common existing
solution and found that the users were
not only able to create more accurate
drawings with it but they were also
enjoying the process more I commend the
authors for taking into consideration
the overall experience of the drawing
process which is an incredibly important
factor if the user enjoyed the process
he'll surely come back for more and of
course the more we show up the more we
learn some of these tutorials are
available on the website of the authors
as always I've linked it in the video
description if you're in the mood to
draw make sure to give it a go and let
us know how it went in the comment
section hell even I am now in the mood
to give this a try if I disappear for a
while you know where I am thanks for
watching
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time
[Music]